les gens n'avaient pas le droit de me
regarder quoi il a insulté
il gueulait ben pourquoi vous regardez
ma femme
Fatou bonsoir
alors faites-nous en 2016
lors de la campagne électorale Nicolas
Sarkozy déclaré à chaque femme
martyrisée dans le monde je veux que la
France offre sa protection en lui
donnant la possibilité de devenir
française vous faites tout votre mari
vous frapper vous êtes allé porter
plainte et la France en profite pour
vous expulser comme quoi quand votre
mari vous frappe il vaut mieux avoir des
papiers en règle on en parlera à 20h
[Musique]
ça tourne bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes né à
Thiès au Sénégal en 1988 et deux sœurs
un frère
oui effectivement une enfance plutôt
joyeuse malgré le divorce de vos parents
oui aux parents ont divorcé parce que
votre père battait votre mère
trois femmes donc elle n'était pas bien
il y avait des phrases
des problèmes et tout ça alors votre
mère s'appelle hobby oui ce saigne au
kadven pour éduquer ses enfants et à
l'école vous travaillez bien vous êtes
toujours dans les cinq premières de la
classe effectivement quand vous arrivez
en terminale de 19 ans c'est du bac et
là on est en décembre 2007 votre
beau-frère invite à Thiès un cousin qui
s'appelle Khalifa qui est français
d'origine sénégalaise qui a 40 ans qui
est beau gosse plutôt baraqué qui a fait
maths sup Maths pas con du tout
alors quand vous le voyez la première
fois vous vous rentrez du lycée vous
flashez pas spécialement sur lui pas du
tout de toute façon j'ai un petit copain
à l'époque oui
mais en revanche ce califat a vraiment
flashé sur vous il en parle à votre sœur
il commence à vous tourner autour un peu
oui c'était un coup de foudre il était
très amoureux il était prête à tout
alors ce califat vous appelle et vous
invite avec votre famille à célébrer le
nouvel an à Dakar voilà vous vous lui
promettez rien et le 31 décembre vous
prêtez un mal au ventre pour pas y aller
parce que j'avais mon copain voilà
mais il se décourage pas non il décale
son retour en France d'une semaine et il
vous dites tu es la femme de ma vie
c'est ma princesse
tu es la femme dont j'ai toujours rêvé
donc c'est toi c'est toi ce califat va
avoir votre mère il lui demande votre
main et votre mère refuse
il rentre en France et là il vous fait
la totale c'est à dire qu'il vous
appelle tous les jours même il vous
envoie sa carte bleue oui
donc ce qui se passe à ce moment-là
c'est normal c'est-à-dire que petit à
petit une certaine complicité s'installe
c'est pas de l'amour mais enfin voilà il
vous écrit des poèmes il vous écrit des
chansons vous n'êtes pas insensible
quand même alors il revient à Thiès donc
au Sénégal en juillet il vous redemande
en mariage vous refusez et finalement
bon votre petit copain de l'époque il en
a un peu marre de ces histoires
on finit par découvrir donc il a un peu
à la fin il m'a dit que c'était fini
d'accord il y a pas de problème parce
qu'il y avait Khalifa moi j'ai comparé
les deux mecs j'avais vu que Khalifa
était plus présent alors qu'il était à
6000 km du Sénégal
très mal en revanche sera LIFA se Califa
on se comporte en prince charmante il
vous sort le grand jeu le matin et vous
amène au lycée en voiture et bien vous
cherchez pour déjeuner le soir et vous
entends la sortie du lycée ah c'est la
totale le mec fait la totale quand vous
avez des problèmes en maths il vous
donne des cours de maths il vous donne
des leçons d'anglais enfin voilà et
quand vous échouez au bac parce que vous
avez quand même
il est là pour vous consoler il vous
redonne confiance si vous changez des
idées enfin un mec extraordinaire il
vous traite comme une princesse vous
êtes sa petite princesse j'ai jamais vu
ça c'est pour ça que je suis tombée dans
le piège
c'est un mec formidable
si on avait ça
mais qu'est-ce que tu as tu es aveugles
ou quoi alors vous cédez pas grand chose
vous lui donnez un baiser sur la bouche
là il y a un truc absolument incroyable
c'est que le Khalifa il vous redemande
en mariage encore une fois c'est la
troisième fois et votre père refuse et
ça ça vous voyez une fois par an ou de
temps en temps quoi donc je me suis
rebelle dit je vais me marier alors là
vous faites un deal avec Khalifa vous
dites écoute c'est pas compliqué moi je
veux bien envisager des choses avec toi
mais une chose qui est sûre c'est que je
veux rester au Sénégal jusqu'à ce que
j'ai mon bac d'ailleurs à ce moment-là
vous lui cédez on peut le dire vous lui
donnez votre virginité pas tout on s'est
marié au mois de juillet après tout ça
donc
ouais il m'a dévier on est parti pour
les noces
donc après ça je suis tombée enceinte
il y avait les études parce que moi je
tiens je tenais beaucoup à mes études
donc je lui dis je vais faire un
avortement alors en mars vous obtenez un
visa pour aller en France
Khalifa veut que vous veniez début avril
non non je ne viens pas on avait dit que
c'était juillet après le bac d'abord je
passe le bac et il vous promet de vous
aider à passer le bac en France vraiment
prêt à tout pour vous faire venir votre
mère vous met un peu la pression vous
dit enfin quand même c'est un beau gars
il a une situation etc vous partez vous
quittez le Sénégal à ce moment-là et
c'est un déchirement pour vous pour moi
si si je venais en France c'était juste
pour trois mois maximum donc je voulais
pas vivre ici donc vous partez vous
arrivez à Paris alors là vous commencez
à des chanter un petit peu faites tout
c'est quand il vous amène chez lui et là
c'est un deux pièces à Créteil parce que
au Sénégal bon on est pas riche on a de
la place mais on a de la place oui des
grandes maisons donc à trouver je lui
dis mais
c'est quoi ça de pièces je vais habiter
ici me débat les apparts ici c'est ça il
y en a même qui ont des studios et tout
donc après je laisse passer voilà en
petite déception mais bon vous apercevez
qu'à Paris vous connaissez personne sauf
votre sœur Michel que vous n'avez pas vu
depuis 10 ans qui habite à Paris donc et
qui vous propose de venir à une fête
d'anniversaire
vous allez à la fête organisée par votre
soeur Michel et là dès que vous arrivez
dans cet appartement
Halifa commence à faire la tête
pas content du tout pas du tout content
parce que à chaque fois que j'étais
seule avec ma sœur il était là
c'est ma femme quoi il était il est
possessif
et alors dans la voiture là ça commence
à tourner vinaigre dans la voiture il
vous dit ta sœur est trop occidentalisée
elle fréquente les blancs si tu la
fréquentes tu vas parler aux blancs tu
vas fumer des cigarettes ça c'est
l'abomination
[Rires]
ces mots là mon choqué parce que
j'attendais pas ça ma sœur à 40 ans donc
il roule comme un malade sur l'autoroute
et il commence et là où ça il commence à
cogner la tête comme ça contre la vie de
la voiture une dispute il m'a insulté je
l'ai insulté et là il tire ma tête
il me frappe quoi il me frappe grave
alors il vous frappe vous voulez vous
suicider vous voulez sortir de la
voiture
des des poignées de cheveux il vous
frappe à nouveau arrivée en bas de chez
vous il vous montre comme ça à la maison
vous tirant par les cheveux il vous
donne les coups de poing
et il sort il vous laisse enfermer chez
lui donc à Créteil sans portable même
les fixes les portables et les filles et
il m'a fermé à clé et ça c'était trois
jours après mon arrivée et là on peut
dire que le prince charmant du Sénégal
se transforme en bourreau de Créteil
heureusement votre sœur Michel c'est
toute une histoire extraordinaire votre
Jean-Michel il est oublié son téléphone
dans votre sac vous appelez la police
vous connaissez pas l'adresse parce que
Sénégal il y a pas d'adresse donc vous
essayez de décrire l'endroit où on est
mais vous y arrivez mal enfin finalement
la police finit par arriver avec votre
sœur Michel et vous partez ici les
Moulineaux oui voilà le lendemain les
parents ne se rallye fac viennent vous
voir ils essaient d'arranger les choses
ils disent voilà c'est notre fils il a
un peu violent mais il va pas
recommencer et il vous supplie de pas
porter plainte ce qui fait que la
première fois où il vous frappe vous ne
portez pas j'avais un certificat médical
et tout j'ai été à l'hôpital alors vous
retournez habiter avec Khalifa Créteil
vous êtes victime de sa jalousie
maladive je vous ai pas le droit de
sortir sans autorisation
il appelle toute la journée sur le
téléphone fixe pour savoir si vous êtes
là quand vous allez au centre commercial
c'est avec lui les gens n'avaient pas le
droit de me regarder quoi qui n'insulter
il gueulait pourquoi vous regardez ma
femme
donc ça s'adérable tout le temps un jour
vous allez acheter des courses seul au
centre commercial il vous frappe
et vous allez acheter un timbre fiscal
pour votre permis de séjour et après
vous dites tiens je vais passer à
château d'eau pour mes ongles je vais me
faire refaire les ongles
il y a les noirs qui respectent rien
donc là-bas il te drague ils font ceci
ils font cela donc
il était vraiment là et bah moi aussi
parce que j'en pouvais plus
n'importe où vous savez pas où aller
d'ailleurs vous êtes dans la gare du RER
à chaque fois que j'arrive au terminus
je reprends de l'autre côté
pendant presque toute la nuit quoi ouais
il vous retrouve il vous ramène il vous
cogne il veut vous étrangler
oui et finalement vous décidez de porter
plainte quand même
la police qui sont venus je leur ai dit
que je ne pouvais plus rester à la
maison et là ils m'ont dit c'est eux qui
m'ont aidé à descendre mes bagages et
tout oui alors là c'est terrible parce
que vous voulez obtenir le divorce et à
ce moment-là la préfecture de police
vous ordonne de quitter la France dans
un délai de un mois cette violence moi
je demande que justice soit faite il y a
une violence j'ai subi j'ai eu des
traumatismes là je veux même plus voir
un mec à cause de qui à cause de Khalifa
est-ce que vous avez toutes les preuves
de ce que vous avancez
policiers qui sont venus trois fois de
suite chez moi donc
un dossier solide parce que ce que vous
êtes en train de dire ce soir c'est
finalement l'État français au lieu de
vous défendre devant ce garçon
extrêmement violent voilà il préfère
vous dire hop oui
française qui était à ma place on allait
pas réagir comme ça en fait sous
prétexte que vous n'êtes pas encore
française parce que il aurait fallu
vivre deux ans avec lui les lois ne
s'appliquent pas à vous à la préfecture
ils m'ont dit que je devais rester
minimum deux ans avec mon mari pour
avoir mais
pendant deux ans pour avoir le droit que
ça plainte soit examinée d'accord donc
je devais rester recevoir du coup tous
les jours peut-être ce serait ma mort
aujourd'hui quelle est la situation en
fait
depuis j'ai pas de réaction on attend
toujours on attend on a écrit
au ministre mon avocat se bat tout comme
moi il m'aide il y a des associations
qui a commencé à faire un petit peu
bouger les choses oui donc là on attend
aussi des réponses et tout et je demande
aussi de l'aide auprès des associations
de oui mais les gens qui peuvent m'aider
quoi parce que moi je veux vraiment que
juste ce soir rendu est-ce que vous êtes
menacé d'expulsion aujourd'hui
là il me reste même pas disons je ne
sais pas 20 jours en France alors que
j'ai rendez-vous devant le juge des
affaires familiales pour
le divorce maintenant là vous avez pas
envie de rentrer chez vous d'oublier
tout ça et de vivre au Sénégal non mais
au moins ce que mon divorce soit
prononcé au moins ce que
la violence que je subis soit corrigée
l'histoire c'est l'occasion de dire
aussi deux mots de la des violences
faites aux femmes dans notre pays
ça fait de massif
qui touche pas seulement effectivement
les gens venus d'autres pays
ça concerne aussi les beaux quartiers je
crois que c'est pratiquement
10% des femmes on considère qu'elles
sont victimes de violence avec une qui
meurt sous les coups d'un proche tous
les deux à trois jours notre pays
c'est tous les milieux
ouais ce qui est terrifiant c'est
les têtes de glaciation de
l'administration une situation complexes
face à une administration qui ou qui n'a
plus la volonté ou le courage ou la
préoccupation d'essayer d'une entrée
dans cette complexité et qui va donner
les réponses et les solutions c'est les
Assas et c'est la presse
si tu me vois
sache que tu m'as gâché ma vie et je
t'en veux et ça sort vraiment du cœur
mais voilà
c'était Salut les terriens et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de innarditude
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu